CHRIS FOLEY: Today,
we're going to talk about
From Systrace to Safety Net,
Android Game Development Case
Studies.
My name is Chris Foley.
I'm a developer advocate working
with games here at Google.
And today, I'm joined onstage
by Damien Mabin, who is
a game engineer from Supercell.
And today, I wanted to
talk about a few things--
it's not just one topic,
it's actually a few topics--
about experiences that
some of the partners
that we've worked with have had
in Android game development.
And some of the topics that
we'll be covering today
will be Systrace.
Then we'll also be talking
about Instant Games.
And, thirdly, we'll be going
over a few case studies
and examples of
how developers have
used app licensing and
SafetyNET Attestation API
in order to
safeguard their game.
So, first of all, I wanted to
talk a little bit about frame
pacing and using Systrace to fix
some issues that Supercell had
with their game "Brawl Stars."
So up here is Damien.
And Damien will be happy
to walk through us what
they did with frame
pacing, or fixing the frame
pacing with Systrace.
And I'll hand it over to him.
And he can start over right now.
DAMIEN MABIN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Damien.
OK.
You might know at Supercell
we have different teams
that are fairly autonomous.
And I work in the
game engineering team.
So I am trying to help
game's team focus on what
they do best, making the game.
I'm trying to deal with platform
issues or technical issues.
And one of them is input latency
in Android has been quite big.
So while investigating
input latancy,
one topic that came very
quickly is frame pacing.
So let's talk a little
bit about frame pacing.
It's just a very
quick intro before we
do more technical explanation.
So here you see the yellow line
is the timeline in the game.
And the green bars are the
Vsync when the display actually
refresh the image.
And what happens
in many games is
the game is going to draw one
frame, frame number one here.
And at the end, it's
going to put it--
that bar is going to
show the number of buffer
being queued for display.
So after drawing
frame number one,
it's going to be
unqueued for display.
And hopefully it's going to
get displayed at the next Vsync
here.
While it's waiting for the
first frame to be displayed,
it's going to draw a second
frame, which will get unqueued
when it's finished drawing.
And the game is
not idle, so it's
going to start during the third
frame, which, in Android, will
also get unqueued,
because Android
allows triple buffering.
So right now we have two
buffer in the queue waiting
to be displayed and one
buffer currently displayed
to the user.
At the next Vsync, frame number
two is going to get displayed.
Sorry.
That's an interesting
bit, actually.
What should happen is
that you should start
during frame number four there.
However, it's going to get
delayed until after the Vsync
because you cannot
acquire one more buffer.
Android doesn't allow it.
It's only triple buffering.
So after the Vsync, frame
number two is being displayed.
Frame number three is
still in the queue.
And you can start draw frame
number four because you
can acquire when buffered.
At the end of drawing
frame number four,
it's going to get unqueued.
And you are in a constant state
of triple buffering right now.
So the next frame is going
to be drawn after the Vsync.
And you are going to unqueue it.
And you are in a constant
state of triple buffering.
I guess the reason
why it's bad is
when you start considering
inputs and the user
feeling of latency between when
the user touches the screen
and does something and when
it happened on the screen.
So let's overlay on that
this yellow-orange bar.
These orange bar represent
the time when Android tell us
something, some input happened.
It's actually tightly
coupled with the Vsync.
So it happened a little
bit after the Vsync.
And if you look at the first
image and the first buffer
on the one, the draw
one, well, the input
happened after the
drawing has started.
So you can imagine the game
cannot really handle the input
right there.
So the game is actually
going to consume
the input on the next
frame, which will then
be rendered during that
frame, which will be unqueued,
which will be consumed
only in the next Vsync.
So here, you are looking at
the latency of one full Vsync
plus maybe 10
milliseconds, which
is 26 milliseconds latency.
It wouldn't be terribly bad.
But if you look at the case
where the game is triple
buffering, for
example, this one,
you start seeing that, between
the time where you receive
the inputs and the time
where it is unqueued,
there is maybe around 18
milliseconds roughly there.
But it is unqueued.
It's not the next
buffer to be displayed.
It's actually the
third-- the second one.
So you are looking at the
whole end-to-end latency
around 40 milliseconds,
which start being noticeable
as a player, especially when you
look at a fast-pace action game
like "Brawl Stars."
So what can we do?
Well, let's take
a look first at--
sorry.
Can we switch to
the laptop, please?
CHRIS FOLEY: Yeah.
DAMIEN MABIN: Oh yeah, good.
Let's take a look
quickly at Systrace.
So when I was
investigating this issue--
sorry.
Give me one second.
OK, when I was investigating
this issue, one thing I was--
better.
One thing I took really
right away is Systrace.
So from far away, it
looks slightly scary.
I am going to try and explain
a bit what's happening there.
OK, so here at the top,
you can see the CPU usage,
which you can see have some
spike on the bottom line that
is pretty constant.
There we can see details about
what's happening on each core.
But we don't care
too much about it.
And then there is two
interesting bits in Systrace.
The first one is something
called SurfaceFlinger.
You can see the name there.
That's an Android
process that is
responsible for composing
the final image drawn
on the screen of your device.
So if you use a
normal app, you will
see that most of the time
you have the UI of the app.
But you also have
the notification bar
at the top on some other
element on the screen.
So SurfaceFlinger
is the one that
takes the notification
bar, the image of the app,
put both of them together
on display on the screen.
So we are going to look into a
bit of the detail of Systrace
later.
And at the bottom
here, we have com
dot Supercell dot
"Brawl Stars," which is
the game I was profiling there.
OK, let's go back to
Systrace a little bit.
And let's zoom a little bit.
So the cool part
of Systrace tool,
if you open it in
Chrome or whatever,
you can navigate it the same
way you navigate in a game.
So W and S lets you
zoom in and out.
And A and D let you go left
and right, which is convenient.
OK, let's take a look here.
So the first thing to notice is
these big gray and white bands
are one frame being
displayed on the screen.
So if you try to measure, each
of these is 16 milliseconds,
right?
It's running at 60 FPS.
So, yeah.
And in SurfaceFlinger,
there is one line here,
SurfaceView com dot
Supercell, which
is all of the buffers that are
being unqueued for rendering.
So if I click on this
one, for example,
you can see there is a value
of two, which means there
is two buffer in the queue.
If you look at here,
there is one buffer
in the queue,
which you can guess
means we are triple buffering.
Two buffer in the queue on
one displayed to the user,
which is pretty bad.
It's the worst case I
was explaining earlier.
OK, and if we look a little
bit more in SurfaceFlinger,
you can see, at the
end of that Vsync here,
there is a whole
lot of things that
are happening in the UI thread.
So this whole lot of things
is what I was explaining.
If I zoom a lot, we can
see dual composition here.
It's taking the different buffer
being displayed in the device
and undoing the composition
to draw it on the screen.
There is an interesting
bit about it.
If you look at that
Vsync here, you
can see that our count
of buffer in the queue
drop a little bit
after the Vsync,
like about 500 microseconds.
The interesting bit
is, naively, when
I looked at it the
first time, I would
believe that drop would happen
at the same time as the Vsync.
It's really interesting,
because what it means
is that that buffer here is
consumed by the UI thread
about there when it's
returned [INAUDIBLE] buffer.
It's later being
composed here, which
means it's only going
to be drawn there.
We will see why it's really
important a little bit later.
But on Android, what
happened is, instead
of consuming that buffer--
yeah, sorry.
Instead of consuming
that buffer here
in order to draw
it on the screen,
it's consuming it here in
order to draw it there,
which have a small impact
on how latency work.
But I am going to
come back to it later.
It's just interesting to
notice that the hardware
composition happened so
much earlier than the Vsync.
OK, now let's take
a look at the game.
That's the current game
that is currently live.
If we looked at it, you
can see our game there
with our open GLThread.
And you see our frame that is
being drawn under all frames
there.
One thing that I
discovered is, at the top,
you can see a thin line that
is either green or red there.
Red is meaning that our
thread is sleeping and not
doing any work.
And green is meaning we are
actually doing some stuff.
So you can see this
Android frame is actually
in a sleep state for a long
while, like 6.5 milliseconds.
And I was wondering
what's happening there.
And what's happening
is that it's not
able to draw because we are in
that state of triple buffering.
So we cannot acquire
one more buffer.
OK, enough talk about
the current state.
Let's look at how it is after
we did some fixes and the frame
facing.
That's a trace that is taken
after we did some fixes.
The first thing that is
interesting to notice
is, from far away, if you
look at the SurfaceFlinger
for the SurfaceView, there
is no more triple buffering.
We are constantly in a
state of double buffering.
Here we have one
buffer in the queue
and then zero,
one and then zero.
So we are constantly
double buffering.
OK, as I was saying earlier,
that frame being consumed here
is being displayed
at that Vsync.
Now, let's take a look at
what are the inputs being
used to draw that frame, because
that's really what matters here
to reduce input latency.
So let me highlight that moment
where we unqueued one buffer
and looked down in the game.
So in that trace, I did a
little bit of information
about what's
happening in the game.
So you can see that, at that
time, we are swapping buffer.
That buffer being swapped
is being drawn there.
And the logic of the
game is being executed
in the game update here.
The interesting bit is
if I keep zooming a bit,
the game update here
is using the inputs
that are delivered
at that point here.
So between that moment--
sorry.
Between that moment when
the frame was being drawn,
when it has been queued--
sorry.
OK, so it has been queued here.
It has been dequeued there.
It will be rendered
here on the screen.
We are at about 32
milliseconds latency
for the input, which is pretty
much the best I could find.
If we look back at
the previous game
and we try to look
at the same number--
OK, here we have
triple buffering.
So let's take a
look at this one.
We have our Android
frame happening here,
which is actually using
the input being delivered--
the previous frame, which
happened around here.
And then, if I look at the
queue, it's being dequeued.
This buffer that is
unqueued there at the top
is not the one being
dequeued there.
It's the one being dequeued
at the next frame, which is
actually being rendered here.
So if I look at the
overall input latency,
we were looking at
something around--
one too many--
47 milliseconds.
So we dropped about
one frame of latency.
Let's take a look at how it
looks in the game in the end,
because, well, that's what
player experience is, right?
I made a small video.
I am not really good
at editing video.
So it's not my primary skill.
I did the best.
So if you look very
carefully, it's
really clear, obvious, right?
No, joking.
I have a frame by
frame thing happening.
OK, so look on the left.
Here, we have our
virtual joystick.
And there, that
white circle is where
the finger is, or pretty much--
it's actually displaying where
Android thinks the finger is.
So I am going to put my
mouse on that white circle.
And I am going to move
forward by one frame.
So you can see my
mouse is still not--
and there is the
virtual joystick.
If I move by one
frame more, now I
have the virtual joystick
under the mouse, which
means that I have two frame
latency between the user input
and the game reacting to it.
Now, if you look on the right--
yeah.
If you look here, for
example, you have the--
that's after the fix.
So you have the user
finger being here.
And if I move by one
frame, the virtual joystick
is on it, which means
we have one frame
latency in the display
between the user input
and the display on the screen.
It's also interesting if I
move a little bit forward
or backward in time, actually.
Ah, sorry.
If you look here, the
distance between the joystick
and the finger is quite big.
If you look at this one,
the distance is quite a lot
shorter.
Ah, sorry.
Yeah, it's quite a
lot shorter, which
means that that also translates
into the latency felt
by the user.
Yeah, that's a result
of the input latency
fix, one frame less.
OK, can we switch back
to the slide, please?
Yeah.
CHRIS FOLEY: Can we
hop on back to the uh--
yeah, thank you.
DAMIEN MABIN: Oh yeah,
so that's about it
for my part on Systrace, on
the Dark Art of Systrace,
on how to understand it.
If you have any questions, I am
happy to chat after the talk.
CHRIS FOLEY: Cool.
DAMIEN MABIN: I am
handing it back to Chris.
CHRISTOPHER FOLEY: Cool.
DAMIEN MABIN: There you are.
CHRISTOPHER FOLEY: Oh
yeah, actually Da-- here,
I had that water.
[LAUGHS]
Cool.
Thank you, Damien.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Yeah, Systrace, it
can be a little bit
frightening at first.
But it's a really powerful
tool for really optimizing
the performance of your game.
So it's all available.
I would encourage
looking into it
if that's something
that you're really
interested in an
really making your game
run smoother and really better.
So moving on, we're going
to move into something
a little more high level.
And this will be Instant
Game referral tracking.
So let me first
talk a little bit
about why you would want to
have Instant Games anyways.
So the traditional game install
flow looks something like this.
There's a user
acquisition event,
like somebody clicks on an ad.
They click on it.
It takes them to the Play
Store, nice big banner
up in the top, Install.
And this is great.
The player wants to
try and play your game.
The idea is they try it,
they find it really exciting,
and they want to play.
Or they go into it
and play, right?
But now they have to install.
Now, that's actually a lot
of friction right there.
You know, it could be up to
100 megabyte download there.
And maybe they're not on Wi-Fi.
Maybe they're on
mobile somewhere.
And if you're a
game developer, I'm
sure you all really know
that, really, the end
result is that often
just getting an install
can be the challenge.
You know that once they play
the game they'll love it.
But you can't even
get to that point.
So this is where
Instant Games come in.
So starting with your
user acquisition flow,
imagine you instead click.
And instead of having
to go to a store,
it just immediately
goes to, well,
this screen right here, which is
Google Play Instant, installing
a game right there.
And they have a demo
version of the game.
This is an instant game that
they can play right away.
There's no install.
They're immediately into
the gameplay experience.
And you can use this
moment to really sell
your game to your player.
And in fact, here on the top
here, there's a little button.
It's hard to read here.
But it says Install Now.
And the instant game is
where you prompt the player
to actually install the game.
But this is after they've had
a chance to really experience
it and really enjoy the game.
And really, this
is why you've made
the game in the first place.
Once they actually decide
that they want to try it,
then you do the install.
Then you actually prompt them.
The game begins to download.
But it doesn't matter
so much at this point,
because you've already
gotten the player involved,
and they're already
really committed to it.
Now, as I'm talking
about this, this
is obviously about
optimizing user acquisition.
And I'm sure that you all
know, if you've done any user
acquisition, that a key part of
this is knowing your analytics,
knowing your metrics, how
effective are your different ad
campaigns, knowing where your
sources of those clicks are.
But the issue is that if you
have an instant game just
naively, the game
will not know where
that source is, because
there's that intervening step.
And so if you look at the
game from its point of view,
it doesn't know
where the source is.
However, there's
a way to fix this.
And that is forwarding the
referral from the Instant Game.
So as it turns out,
the Instant Game
gets the same
referral information
that a regular
game install would.
So the problem or, really,
the issue is, at that point,
you just have to
collect that data
and somehow get that
to the full game.
And this is how it's done.
So you first collect
the referral data
by adding this code to the
Instant Games onCreate.
And you can see
we get the intent.
We do a little
processing about it.
Then at the bottom, you pull the
parameters out of the intent.
And then here, they even
add an extra parameter
onto that, which is from IG,
Instant Game, equals true.
Then you then include
this referral data
as an additional parameter
for showInstallPrompt,
which is the part
in the Instant Game
where you actually are prompting
the user, well, to obviously
install the full game.
And then the full game
will get those parameters
and then can use those to send
those on and track your user
acquisition referral
information.
So this is how it
works in real life.
So forwarding Instant
Game referral strings,
let's say we have ad
campaign number two.
And here I have it.
So say somebody in Columbia here
clicks on an ad for your game.
Now, the referral link will
look something like this.
This is obviously a generic one.
But there's your
link to the store.
Now, at the bottom, you
have your referral source.
And it's a little
bit URL encoded.
But it says source will
equal the AdCampaign2.
That's where the
source came from.
And then down at the
bottom is launch=true,
which tells the Instant Game
to immediately start installing
and downloading the game,
which is what you want,
lowers the amount of friction
for getting into the game.
Now, in the Instant
Game, there's
the code I just showed you
that pulls the parameter out.
Then at the bottom, you
show the InstallPrompt.
Now, the full game now
has the full information.
It has the source, AdCampaign2.
And there's even our additional
source which is fromIG=true.
Now you have even
more information
about your acquisition.
And lastly then, of
course, you send that back
to your own servers,
your own analytics.
And this is how you can actually
see the full impact of your ad
campaign and with Instant Games.
So onto my last
topic today, which
is talking about ensuring
the integrity of your game.
So I'm sure you're all
aware, as game developers,
that you want people
to play your game.
And that's great.
But when you have
a game out there,
it's also going to
attract bad actors, people
who want to cheat, people
who want to hack the game,
maybe people who want to maybe
take advantage of other players
or maybe hurt their experience.
There's lots of different
areas out there.
And these all come in from
different modes of attack,
which are like modded
APKs, or pirated APKs,
or emulators out there, which
are not bad in themselves,
obviously, but can be used
in various attempts, too.
You have rooted devices,
once again, not bad in itself
but can be used to launch
various attacks onto the game,
such as memory attacks.
And so if you're thinking about,
how do I keep my game safe?
How do I protect the integrity?
How do I protect my player
base from having our ecosystem
hacked in some way?
And it really boils
down to two parts.
First of all, can the
binary be trusted?
In particular, did the
binary come from somewhere
that I trust?
Is it from a known source?
And the second part is, can
the device itself be trusted?
Because, obviously,
if you're just
listening to the app itself, if
you an APK, and the APK says,
hey, I'm great, I came
from a great place,
but you don't own the
device, and the device
might be hacked or
modified in some way, that
could change that.
So you want to make sure that
the device is OK as well.
So for the first part,
can the binary be trusted,
there is app licensing.
And for the second part,
can the device be trusted,
there's the SafetyNet
Attestation API.
And these two
parts work together
to help ensure the
integrity of your game.
And let me talk a little
bit more about how this is.
App licensing works like this.
Say you have a game
and you want to know,
did this game-- was this APK
downloaded from the Play Store?
So the game at startup,
you're launching,
and it's doing all its
setup and initialization.
And at this point, it calls
the app licensing, API,
checkAccess, which reaches out
to the license verification
server for Play and says,
does the Google user here
or does the Play user--
have they ever downloaded
this game from the store?
Assuming it says
yes, then it returns
with a valid license, which
triggers the license checker
callback.
And the player is
allowed into the game.
Likewise, suppose they
don't have a license.
Suppose they haven't downloaded
the APK from Play Store.
Maybe they side
loaded it somewhere.
Maybe it was distributed
somewhere else.
Then it returns with no license,
which comes back to the license
checker callback.
And you have a mechanism
of blocking-- keeping
the player out of the game.
The second thing is
SafetyNet integrity check.
And this is a little
bit more complicated.
As I said, you don't really want
to trust anything on the device
if you're checking to
see if the device itself
has been compromised.
So this has to be
initialized from the backend.
So in this case, here
we have "Brawl Stars."
And there's Supercell backend.
And that initializes--
initiates the check.
It does that by sending a nonce,
a small, unique ID that you're
going to associate
with this request
all the way through
this process.
And I'll get to the
why in a second.
The backend sends a
nonce to the game.
The game at this point
uses that nonce, adds it
onto the API call, which goes
to the SafetyNet Attestation API
on the device,
which then forwards
that back onto the Google
Attestation API backend.
Now, this backend has a lot
of different signals and ways
of checking if the device
itself has been compromised
or if it hasn't been certified,
if it is not certified,
or if it is certified.
And it uses all these
different signals
to basically return back to you.
It says, this device is good
or maybe it isn't so good.
Whatever that response
is gets sent back
to the SafetyNet
Attestation API,
which then comes
back to the game
itself forward or
back onto the backend.
Now, the backend here
is going to then check
to see whether or not this--
this is where you actually
are checking the response here.
Like I said, you don't want
to trust the device just yet.
So if you have a
valid attestation
and the nonce matches--
now, the reason
you have that nonce
is to protect against
replay attacks.
Because there could be
a hack, for example,
that takes a valid attestation
and responds back and says,
hey, everything's good,
even though it isn't.
However, they won't
have the corrected nonce
that you've attached with that.
And that's why you initiate
that from the backend.
You also want to check a few
other things like timestamps,
just in case something else is--
there's a few other checks
that you put into there.
But assuming
everything works out,
says good, lets the
player into the game.
So this is how SafetyNet
Integrity Check works.
So how does this work
in the real life?
And how can you use
this to try your game?
So I have a couple of
interesting cases here.
The first is from Rovio.
Now, Rovio has a game
named "Angry Birds 2,"
which maybe you've heard of.
Now, obviously, "Angry Birds 2,"
a huge game, global, worldwide.
And it also has a
global leaderboard.
Now, if you're thinking
if it is a popular game
and it has a leaderboard that
everyone in the world to see--
wants to see, there are
going to be a lot of attacks
on this leaderboard.
Because a lot of people want
to cheat and get their name
on the top of that leaderboard.
So Rovio was seeing a
lot of attacks coming in.
And there were two main ways
of attacking the leaderboard
that they saw.
The first was tampered APKs,
modified APKs somewhere
that people were side loading.
And the second one was a
memory attack, an access
to the memory of the game.
Now, this is only possible
on a rooted device.
So this is a perfect
use case for SafetyNet,
which is checking to see if the
device has been rooted or not.
Because if it's been
rooted, then you
can't really trust that
the device is really
as it always was.
Maybe there was a custom
ROM or something else.
So Rovio implemented
SafetyNet Attestation API.
And the results were
pretty good for them.
What they saw was,
first of all, right off
the top, 40% fewer hack
attempts on their leaderboard.
I mean, if you think about
it, that's 40% fewer attacks
you have to defend against.
It's a much more safer
environment for their game.
It's less that they
have to work on.
Whoops, sorry.
Clicked a little bit.
It helps with their
resource management
as far as managing the game.
It's less effort for
protecting the game.
And then second of
all, what they saw
was there was a higher
degree of spenders
in their top leaderboard.
Which if you think
about, this makes sense.
And this is really what
they wanted to see.
Because you don't
want to see hackers
in the top of the leaderboard.
You don't want to see people
who are there who don't really
care about the game.
They just want to show off
like, hey, I'm great at this.
Instead, the
leaderboard was actually
showing real players, people
who were really committed
and dedicated to the game.
Those are the ones that you
would expect to actually
be on the leaderboard.
And that's actually
what Rovio got.
So as a result, it
really helped the game.
It helped their community.
It helped their leaderboard.
It helped the ecosystem
of their game.
They were very, very
happy with the results.
And finally, for the
last case I wanted
to talk about today, which is
reducing beta leakage with app
licensing and
SafetyNet together.
Now, first of all,
what is beta leakage?
So some people call it beta.
Some call it a soft launch.
But the idea is before
you do your full launch,
before you give your game
out to the rest of world,
you might want to try a limited
release, a soft launch where
you have maybe a few territories
where people are trying out
the game.
You start getting
feedback on it.
some information
about the resources
used by the game,
maybe how many servers you need
for it, and so on, and kind of
see if the game is actually
working like you think.
So that's what your beta is.
But you want to keep it limited.
You don't want
everyone out there,
because your game--
well, this isn't really
ready for the full world.
But beta leakage is when
that doesn't happen,
where instead of having
a few territories playing
the game, now you have
people from everywhere
playing the game.
And this can be really bad
for your game management,
because now all of your
projections on how much
server usage, or the
demographics of your users,
or, say, the actions or the
behavior of your audience
are going to be completely
out of whack from what you may
have expected to begin with.
And this is a real problem.
Because especially for games
that are very, very, very
popular or really highly
anticipated games,
you get a lot of people who
might want to get that APK even
if they're not in one
of those territories
where they're allowed to.
And in fact, one of our
partners that we worked with
saw a real issue with this.
So they saw in our past
Android soft launches
that 90% of their beta users
came from non-beta countries.
Because they're
able to see where
these players were
playing normally.
But in this case, now, when
they want to play the beta,
suddenly they're able to
play even though they're not
in that place?
And the reason for this is that,
well, Android is really open.
I mean, that's very cool.
I mean, that's one of the best
things about the platform.
And sharing APKs is also
quite straightforward.
You can pull an APK.
You can share it around,
distribute it to your friends,
and so on, and maybe
on different forums.
And so, really, the challenge
for the game developer
who wants to keep
their beta limited
is, how do you prevent your
soft launch from unintentionally
becoming a global launch?
And this is where app licensing
comes in and SafetyNet.
So as I mentioned, sharing
outside of beta regions
typically happens
via sharing APKs.
Now, in this beta,
only the people
that were in those
few beta countries
could actually legitimately
download the APK
from the Play Store.
So if you had the APK and
you're not from a beta country,
you would not have a
valid license for it.
As a result, app
licensing, which
ensures that that APK actually
came from the Play Store, well,
that's the first
thing you want to use.
And that is how you
can prevent people
from playing the game in places
where you maybe didn't intend.
Now, as I mentioned,
SafetyNet, of course,
is needed to check
your device integrity.
Make sure that you can
trust that app licensing
to begin with.
Now, what was the
result of this?
Well, the developer
we worked with on this
saw a huge reduction in the
number of non-beta users.
They saw a 50% reduction in the
number of their beta players
who came from
non-beta countries.
And 50%, that's huge.
The developer was
really, really,
really happy about this.
And for me, this was
actually the first time
I'd seen a developer use this
for locking down their beta.
And I think it's actually a
very, very interesting use
case.
So if you have a game
that's coming out
and you're worried about
maybe keeping it only
in a certain region, this is
something I would actually
take a look at.
So finally, just
kind of recover--
talk again about
what I covered today.
So first of all, we
talked about Systrace.
And Damien was very
helpful on going
through very in-depth on how
they use Systrace to help fix
some of the frame pacing as
they saw in "Brawl Stars."
Next, we talked
about Instant Game
and how you can forward
your referral information
from the instant
game to the full game
to really take full advantage of
the increased user acquisition
that Instant Games provides.
And then lastly, we
went over a couple
interesting use cases of using
app licensing and SafetyNet
to help protect
your game and really
protect your ecosystem
against bad actors that
might be out there.
So with that, I'd like
to conclude my talk.
And first of all, I'd like to
give a huge thanks to Supercell
and Rovio for allowing
me to discuss their games
and use some of their images
to help spice up my talk.
And I'd also like
to thank all of you
for sitting through my
talk and listening to me.
I hope it's been instructive.
And I would
encourage you to look
into these issues
on the Play Store
or in the Android documentation
if you're interested.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]